I find that even with cancer if you have
that belief I'm going to try all this
stuff but it won't work and you know
it's I'm riddled with it and there's no
hope and they start to read all these
terrible diagnoses I mean in England you
are not allowed to say to them you've
got 10 months to live because that's
what happens they turn into the 10
months you cannot diagnose what do they
tell them they just say you know we're
going to do this and this and you may
not survive this but you could and in
the same way that if you're having
surgery and they go look this is a
complete mess in here there's just no
way even in surgery your subconscious is
hearing what's going on around you and
there are many people who come out of a
coma who said you know I heard
everything the hearing is the last thing
to go if you make a choice to talk to
yourself better you can bounce back you
might as well use your mind as much as
you possibly can to be well
what you believe about yourself is the
only thing that matters at the end of
the day no matter how much outside
affirmations you get or other people
telling you that you're amazing if you
don't believe in your heart that you are
amazing it won't none of that will last
like you've ever gone to an event or you
ever made a video or created something
or you're hanging out with a friend and
they tell you how amazing you are and
that feels good right like the external
affirmations and validation feels great
but then it fades but that stuff doesn't
last you don't have somebody being a
cheerleader for you every day showing up
in your bedroom saying hooray go do this
you're amazing right we don't have that
you have to be that for yourself
if you're constantly only getting your
value as a human being from other people
when they tell you that you're amazing
you're never gonna love your life you're
never gonna love yourself
it has to come from you has to come from
you telling yourself and you believe in
that you are amazing
well okay so that's that's a lot of
words how do you actually go off and do
it
I think for me this is why I believe
that lack of belief is the world's
number one problem
you know I can go and meet somebody and
fill them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they they had before
because they don't believe in themselves
enough
and so you have to design habits and
routines in systems and schedules to
slowly shift your belief in yourself
forward
every single day
and a good chunk of that is what you say
about yourself
when you look at yourself in the mirror
what do you say when you think about
yourself what do you say a lot of a lot
of the stuff that we say about ourselves
we wouldn't we wouldn't say to our worst
enemies it's rough
I actually think it's great to be your
own worst critic
I think it's great I think honestly I
think for a lot of people
um we're not hard enough on ourselves
let me let me stick with me for a minute
we're not hard enough on ourselves
because in order to get to where you
want to go you actually need to push
yourself more the problem is why we
can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things we're very
hard on ourselves but because there's no
self-love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like sitting here in a parking lot these
you know those I guess I guess it's kind
of blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives
they're barely hanging on most people
are barely hanging on
really hanging on to what we're doing we
we can post all these great things on
Instagram or wherever and make it look
like we're enjoying our life but most
people are barely hanging on the people
who are judging you for your life and
telling you that you suck hate their own
lives they are barely hanging on so how
do we get through it well yes we can be
harder on ourselves but we need to
balance that with more self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great what you're proud of what
you're grateful for
and it has to be consistent otherwise
you'll never get to where you want to go
and when you love yourself more that
actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself when you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because it's not going to push you over
the edge because you're not tying your
self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
it's starting from a place of I'm
amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself when I go to events
a YouTube event for example if I'm
talking about anything entrepreneurship
or YouTube related
um I'm going in thinking
I'm Kick-Ass
and because I feel that I don't need to
say that
like a lot of times we feel like we need
to say that because it's it's masking
and insecurity right it's like those
people who uh have you ever seen those
memes where
when people make a little bit of money
they've got all these chains and
everything but then the people who are
Ultra rich
who have all the money
you look even Jay-Z like early Jay-Z you
know he's got all this change and
everything and I was like doesn't care
you know just walking on a T-shirt and
some jeans
because he doesn't need to front
because he's just so self-confident now
that it doesn't matter now it's actually
expression instead of masculine
insecurity most of us are just masking
insecurities instead of actually being
self-confident and so when I'm going to
an event if I'm talking about YouTube
I'm walking in feeling amazing
and I don't need to
I don't need to walk around and say hey
look at me
and it's actually the opposite I can go
up and say hey where do I suck it's my
favorite question to ask why do I suck
where do I suck can you point it out if
I can find one person to tell me where I
suck at something how my videos suck my
thumbnails suck do I don't believe that
they suck
right
I think they're amazing
but because I think they're so amazing
it allows me to go a lot harder on
myself
and so people will give their honest
opinion and say hey here's how I think
it could be better
and so I think we need to do that more
in our lives we need to cheer ourselves
up more we need to cheer ourselves on
more so how do we do it let me let me
share some practical tips for you to
execute number one
music in the morning
every morning one of the most important
things that I do is I put music on and
it's music that makes me move makes me
dance makes me there's some songs that
if it came on you would have to you
would have to move right it doesn't mean
that you're up and like dancing through
the whole house going crazy in your
underwear first thing in the morning but
something that even if it's just making
your head Bob
there are songs if they came on would
make your head Bob and you'd probably be
singing maybe not out loud but singing
under your breath I'm gonna tune along
and be intentional with the lyrics
because if we're singing Out lyrics that
are negative
that has a lasting impact but if you're
singing Out lyrics that are positive
that also has a lasting impact
so be intentional with music that you
put on Every Day first start your day
with music it's the fastest way to
change your state to go from feeling low
and tired and just what what day is it
what am I doing I wake up every day like
what day is it what am I doing today
yeah it's but I demand excellence and
that that starts with music because I
don't have I don't want to spend a lot
of time trying to get into the right
state of mind I can command it whenever
I want just by putting on the right song
so be in tension with your music and the
lyrics being positive two
connect to the work that you're doing
and how meaningful it is
so the next thing I'll do is I'll take
the dogs out and then I'll go for what I
call a believe walk and it's probably
the most important part of my morning
routine is I go for a believe walk and
it's a minimum of 20 minutes and it's a
maximum of an hour
and I'll go for a walk by myself with 20
pounds on my back I'll go rocking a walk
to Tim Hortons usually get a coffee you
know this costs two bucks two something
so I only had you know what's the what's
the best money I spend every year well
it's the 700 bucks
of going on my believe walk and getting
a coffee every morning and I'm thinking
about what's my intention for the day
and I'm thinking about what I want to
accomplish today and the lives that I
want to serve and the people I want to
help and and what I'm about to do today
and
it's a mini celebration
where most of the time we wake up like
an accident right you wake up you're
probably late for something you
immediately look at your phone what's on
your phone it's other people's demands
for your time other people's emergencies
of what they think you should do with
your schedule today right that's what's
in your phone all the DMS and the emails
and the texts and the missed calls and
all it's all other people's agenda for
your time that that is not an
intentional life we wake up like an
accident and start falling into what
other people want us to do today that's
not what you need to do and you need to
protect your time so the morning
having to believe walk for me if you
want to go on your own whether it's 20
minutes or an hour that's really just a
feel thing too I don't book anything
until 10 30 at the earliest in my
calendar most of my meetings would be 11
first meeting would be 11 movement
makers and brand lytics I'll start at 10
30. uh and before that there's nothing
officially planned or scheduled so that
it gives my morning free to do whatever
I want to do and so if I want to go for
a hour-long believe walk instead of 20
minutes I can do that because I'm
thinking because I'm brainstorming
because I'm I'm
going through an idea I treat that as
walking meditation
if you like to meditate meditate I mean
it's the same thing I just find
meditation doesn't really help me that
much I like something a little more
active so I go I believe walks
do those two things
put on a playlist put on music every
morning
with lyrics that inspire you
and then go for a believe walk
20 minutes
to think about what you want to do today
what you want to accomplish how you want
to spend your time where you want to be
intentional
so you can start living the life that
you want to live
because the only thing that matters how
you feel about yourself
are you proud of you today
are you happy with what you've done
today
are you
joyful in how you showed up for you
today and yes we ultimately want to
serve and help others
but the only thing that matters is how
you feel about yourself
so we can stop relying on external
validation and somebody else's words of
affirmation for us to
feel Worthy
and flip it to say I am worthy I am
amazing
I can do great things
and when you can shift into that energy
you will do great things
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
what is interesting is we in rtt have
something called role function purpose
so we say to people
this headache had a role what would it
be if um your irritable bowel had a role
if these panic attacks had a purpose and
they come up with the most profound
stuff but it's only ever three things in
30 years is always the same three
the panic attacks protect me you know my
dad wanted me to be a family lawyer like
him but when I got panic attacks so you
could never do that no you can't how
could you ever be in court with panic
attacks so they protected me from this
expectation
I knew I could never meet the second
thing is they punished me you think why
would my mind punish me but
when I talk to people like yeah you know
I had an affair with my friend's
boyfriend and
I it caused so many problems and now
I've got colitis I've got autoimmune
which means the body is attacking itself
when I was 15 I stole money from my
mum's purse and then I never told her
but ever since I've had this chronic
irritable bowel this terrible headaches
I blush all the time you know years ago
we used to go to do pendants we were
used to wear hair shirts but if you have
guilt
your mind's job is to become judge
jurora Jailer let me punish you
so punishing ourselves is is huge a lot
of people do it they don't even know why
and the third thing is get attention
you've all seen kids lying on the floor
in the store screaming because they want
attention that was me getting sick
because they want attention you know
many many children who can't get if you
can't get the love of your parents the
very next best thing is to be sick
oh I didn't think my mom laughing but
she's driving all over town buying this
gluten-free flour getting this special
cream doing something and for many kids
being sick is like oh I didn't think I
mattered but clearly I do now you've got
all this special stuff in the house
yeah the more attention I get more yeah
and those children tend to become
life's hypochondriac so my mother in
England in the war they evacuated
children they took all the children from
cities put them on trains sent to the
country the first thing that people who
are incredibly successful do is they do
what they hate they are fully prepared
to do what they hate to get to where
they want to be and and people who fail
they will give up their dream before
they do what they hate to do people who
are very successful they never ever ever
wait for motivation they do it because
when you do it you become motivated a
great writer won't go well I'll just
wait till I'm really motivated to start
writing this book no they get up at four
in the morning they don't want to and
they start to write and then of course
they become motivated you wake up in the
morning and you go you're not going to
go yay it's 5am I'm putting on my
running shoes and going for a walk up
Laurel Canyon
of course you're not going to do that
you're going to wake up and go go I
really hate working out but Marissa said
successful people do what they hate to
get to where they want to be of course
the wonderful thing is that when you do
what you hate first enough times it
starts to become natural like I've got
to do my taxes I'll do that first thing
I've got to confront someone
um I'll do it first and so I still to
this day wake up and think oh I don't
really want to do that so I'm going to
do it first because what I do want is to
belong to that group of very very
successful people so I know what the
membership is and every time I don't
want to do something I think I don't
want to do it but what I do want is to
belong to that group so I'm doing it
first and it's it's a great way of
thinking because it starts to move you
around wanting to do it for all the
right reasons many many years ago I'm I
met someone who wanted to be a rock star
that was his ambition actually
particularly wanted to be a drummer and
he was a very young married man with two
children to support
and he was going for a lot of auditions
and of course all the auditions take
place during the day and every time he
had a job they wouldn't let him take
time off so he decided he would have to
work nights in order to audition during
the day and the only job he could get
was a job he hated he was a taxi driver
and he hated it but he did it but he
just wasn't making enough money so he
thought okay I have to work at
McDonald's I get more money I can work
nights I'm free to audition and about a
month before he'd applied to work at
McDonald's he'd been for an audition to
be a drummer in a band he didn't know
who the band was and the day he was due
to start working at McDonald's which he
absolutely hated even the thought of he
got a call to go you know that band you
auditioned for it was actually simple
minds and now you're the drummer in
Simple Minds that he never worked in
McDonald's or drove a cab again for the
rest of his life but when he told people
that story they'd all go oh I would
never work in McDonald's oh my God I'd
never degrade Myself by driving a around
London and I'm like don't you think
you're missing the point
his ability to do what he hated is what
made him a rock star because he had to
have his days free to rehearse and
audition but if he had your mindset I'd
never do that he would never be a
multi-millionaire rock star it was
because he was fully prepared to do what
he hated to swallow his pride to keep
his vision in mind I want to be a rock
star I must be free for auditions how
can I do that well I have to work as a
cab driver and in a fast food restaurant
which I hate but I'm going to do it
because it's going to take me to my goal
and it did but the people who laughed
him and said I wouldn't do that none of
them are rock star we have this belief
that our brain's job is to make us happy
oh no your brain's jewel is to make you
survive I didn't care if you're happy it
cares if you survive So when you say my
job is killing me this commute is
stressing me out I'm dying under the
paperwork it wants you to stop
and so because you're my brain's job is
to move you towards pleasure you've got
to say I love working weekends even if
it's not true I love going to the gym
I'm so lucky I've got a baby that wakes
me up at three in the morning I know it
sounds really Pollyanna but you can
trick your mind all the time going I
love it I want it I like it and that's
what Olympic athletes do when they're
training when they're getting up at 3am
to run they don't go oh this is great
but they also don't go my God I hate it
they go yeah this is going to make me an
Olympic Athlete because they understand
the minds need to move you towards
pleasure and away from Pain and if you
link pain to something your mind will
make you give it up really quickly and
people who fail give up their dreams are
very pain to them
who succeed me their dreams they go yeah
I want to work all weekend I'm building
a business I want to work nights writing
this book so I'm going to write a book
you can choose what to link pain and
pleasure to in fact you can choose
anything you like but you know what you
can't choose
what happens when you say things like I
hate my job I Hate My Boss my in-laws
are killing me this kid is driving me
crazy sure you can chew to say that but
you can't choose what happens when you
are very negative if you don't have
self-belief you're not going to get
anywhere if you have extraordinary
self-belief very little Talent you can
get everywhere but if you have both if
you have talent and belief it will
actually make you Unstoppable and I work
with a lot of football teams a lot of
football players and a lot of those
footballers come out of school at 14
they know they're going to be famous
players they don't really pursue an
education a lot of them have
extraordinary negative self-belief
because they're only good at sport which
is a great shame and I'm one of my
players at the moment has now become a
fantastic commentator but I do a lot of
work with him to put in him that belief
because he wasn't great at spelling and
he wasn't great at school because he
knew he's going to be a footballer
so
belief without Talent will take you far
further than Talent without belief but
if you have both you can go far but
everyone can learn self-belief you
mentioned something about
leaning into the feelings until you're
no longer need to feel them or until
they go away feel the feeling and it no
longer requires to be felt why do we why
should we do that so give an example of
this okay so let's imagine you you and
your ex-wife are not getting on and you
have a feeling of Rage about the fact
that she's trying to get your kid to
call the new guy daddy and she's
blocking you out and you feel so angry
you think I mustn't feel angry you know
she's doing it for the interest of my
kid or and so I just drink the anger and
I drink the anger and you see with the
feeling it's the most real thing you
have a feeling is like a little kid and
a class going notice me I'm over here
and if you don't they get more and more
out of control and so when you don't
acknowledge your feelings they regroup
and they regroup until they become
outrage rage coming out and then
suddenly they go a bit crazy in the car
park of the store or the line of a store
because the mind says I've got all this
rage wants to come out someone just cut
in to the Line Take It Out On them and
it's so ineffective because I have
something I call
Triple A which is be aware of your
feeling most people have no idea what
they feel they go I shouldn't feel
jealous I shouldn't feel envious I
shouldn't be furious with this kid who's
keeping me up all night so they're not
aware of it they certainly can't accept
and they never get to articulate if you
can say you know my wife's a good person
but actually I'm furious with what she's
doing it really hurts my feelings that's
why group therapy in places like AAA the
good thing is you get to say sometimes I
could quite cheerfully
hurt my wife I'm not going to but I feel
like oh yeah I feel like that too
because when you can express your
feeling it goes away it goes away
immediately but when you educate it yeah
even to yourself so if your
mother-in-law is the absolute from
hell and you can't say by the way
Dorothy you are the most horrible
mother-in-law in the world
but you just go and shut yourself in the
bathroom turn on the Taps flutter and
say Dorothy is a really unpleasant
mother-in-law
I feel so much better because you're not
saying it to them it's like feelings are
like gas they're in or they're out and
they hurt much more when you keep them
in and you want to let them out maybe
after we're not obviously right in the
middle of a meeting but when you keep
stuffing it causes you pain you really
need to make familiar here's something
that will change your life if you make
it familiar
praise yourself say I did a great job I
did a good job you know in the days of
startup where you're running your own
business it may take two years before we
see a profit the only person who's going
to praise you at the end of every day is
you so say I did a great job did a
really good job today I love what I'm
doing I'm good at it make praise
familiar everyone's good at something
you know you're not meant to be good at
everything it's no good being a jack of
all trades and a master of none so be
really good at what you're good at and
don't worry about what you're not good
at because we're not all supposed to be
good at the same thing
find your talent you know find out what
you love to do what you're meant to do
lies directly behind and is absolutely
linked to what you love to do when I was
a kid actually I loved writings little
stories and illustrating them and it's
funny that now I am very successful
writer because I was always writing when
I was a kid but I never considered that
as a career but it kind of found me
later
my daughter was always drawing and
always in fact she went to college to be
a criminologist and then gave that up
and became an artist because it's what
she was meant to do so find out what you
love and be brilliant at it and believe
in yourself you can't do that you'll
mess it up you'll never get it right
you're just not good at that I want you
to change that voice to a cheerleader a
parent who dotes on you a teacher who
thinks you are the best thing in the
world and I want you to hear that voice
saying yay you can do it you're amazing
this is your air of Excellence you're
good at this you know if you're a kid
running a race at school you want your
parent to be they're going come on come
on you're brilliant you're amazing if
you were doing an assignment at school
you want the teacher or your parent to
go you're very smart you're really good
at writing this is your skill set
so I want you to become a loving parent
to yourself a praising teacher a
cheerleader that always goes yes you can
do this this is easy for you this is a
walk in the park or you have the skills
the talent you've read that book you
know the answers you've studied so
that's how you stop being your own worst
critic the other thing very successful
people do is that they they just don't
take no for an answer they get rejected
everyone gets rejected when they come
back
they do not take no for an answer and
you know I remember working with Luther
Vandross in one of my shows and he
unfortunately he's died now and he said
you know people call me an overnight
success Richard Gere said exactly the
same thing do you know that overnight
success he said it took me 12 years
singing Jingles for Kentucky Fried
Chicken before I got a record deal there
is no overnight success they get
rejected but they come back over and
over and over again self-esteem means
how much you like yourself but when you
like yourself you also like other people
too you can't like yourself and not like
other people there's a lot of violence
and aggression would end if we could
just learn how to like ourselves and
other people rather than feel
dissatisfied with ourselves which means
of course you're dissatisfied with
someone else because if you don't like
yourself and you feel dissatisfied you
want everyone around you to be like that
too and then you feel a bit better
because you're in the same company if
you don't feel very good and everyone
around you is happy then what you want
what people do is they tend to try and
diminish everyone else or Elevate
themselves but you can't Elevate
yourself if you don't like yourself so a
lot of the issues we have in schools the
violence the truanting they're not
achieving could be cut in half if you
just taught children to really like
themselves and to have self-esteem when
you focus on the worst possible outcome
you actually feel as if you are in that
worst possible outcome the only way to
overcome a fear is instead of focusing
on the worst possible outcome to focus
on the best possible outcome I'm driving
it's foggy it's dark it's icy I might
just get off the road and kill myself or
I'm driving very carefully I'm driving
very slowly I'm driving very cautiously
because I'm going to be safe and I'm
going to get home see that's the
difference you just have to give
yourself different beliefs the thing
with fear always is you have two choices
rationalize where you feel so terrible
or talk yourself out of you know I was
on the beach with my daughter and there
was a big dog and it was quite a scary
dog and she didn't like this dog and I
said to you know darling when you don't
like a dog you get very scared and the
dog doesn't like it either and he gets
scared so when you see a scary dog turn
your back to it don't look at it because
when you look at it you're challenging
it and that's hard to do to turn your
back on a dog but if you turn your back
it's not a challenge and she understood
that and I was always teaching her when
you have a fear you have a choice oh my
God that dog's going to bite me attack
me hurt me or I'm going to talk myself
I'm going to turn away I'm going to
breathe they're going to be really calm
and that dog's just going to go on its
way and it's the same with everything in
life to do with fear rationalize why you
feel so fearful or
talk yourself out of it I'll be fine
this is okay everything's gonna work out
perfectly I'm okay all of these fears
hold you back and they don't have to
because every fear you go through
teaches you something you see if you go
to a fun phone go to those loop the loop
rides you can scream in Terror or you
can scream in excitement and the fact
that people put themselves through those
rides means that at some level we quite
like fear it challenges us to do more it
challenges us to grow more so don't fear
fear remember the only fear to fear is
fear itself I don't do no I refuse to
take no for an answer so if I'm told no
you know and I told you can't have a
baby or you'll never be able to do that
I don't I don't let that in which I find
very useful
um I do let in criticism but only if
it's useful
and so I'd say that's probably my best
attitude I just won't take no for an
answer and I was studying once um
celebrities because there were a lot of
them and I mean I don't put myself in
that category but what I found out was
that celebrities don't take no for an
answer they're very interesting they
simply refuse to do no and if you say to
them okay we're having a party
everyone's coming wearing white those
set up in green because they want to be
a little bit different but they don't
see it as a handicap they see it as an
asset
and it's a it's a great thing to not
take no for an answer we used to live in
Ward cities and and our strength came
from numbers we walked we were in a
group and when numbers we survived now
you can live in an apartment you can
have cats and dogs you can have your
grocery job you can never see anyone and
you could live till you're 110. but we
still feel this feeling our die if you
reject me no you are
you I'm in a special
500 years ago you're a hunter-gatherer
and your guy died out sparing a wild at
least you would die who's going to raise
your children who's going to feed you
so in our evolutionary psychology we
have this fear I'll die if you don't
like me and we tried to get over it by
buying stuff and going to the gym and
having a hair down or getting a nicer
car
are trying to impress people and what
you should do is impress upon your mind
look I know you think I'm going to die
from rejection I'm not I actually it's
going to make me stronger and if you can
dialogue with yourself and go okay I've
just been dumped I feel a bit sad it's
not going to kill me it's that was a
starter relationship the next one is
going to be way better than it does make
you stronger the third thing you must do
to really feel great about yourself all
that I'm going to radiate confidence
that real inner confidence is to learn
not to let in destructive criticism now
you can't stop people criticized you
cannot let it in years and years and
years ago when I was getting
engaged to my boyfriend my boss actually
said to me when I said oh I'm I'm gonna
need some time if I'm getting married
she went oh my God your boyfriend's so
good looking how on Earth have you got
him
to marry you I remember thinking wow
that's a bit hardcore and I could have
said something like
um oh yeah I have to handcuff him to the
bed he's so good looking but you see
that's letting it in and having to come
back I could have said how dare you say
that to me so I just said to her oh it's
called love you know we love each other
um and I didn't let it in because I
thought wow that's she must be really
unhappy person to do that but much much
later it's obviously a different
boyfriend someone said to me God your
boyfriend is so unattractive you could
do so much better why are you with him
and I went
that's what an amazing guy he is because
I've never even seen that I just think
he's incredible and my daughter said
remember he's really ugly and I said
yeah I know and I love him so much which
shows what a great guy he must be
because I just think he's gorgeous
and of course my daughter then realized
that she couldn't go anywhere with that
because I didn't let it in and so if you
can learn not to let in destructive
criticism that too will change your life
here's some things I want you to start
doing today right now that will build
your self-esteem super fast the number
one thing
is to praise yourself there is nothing
nothing
that will build your self-esteem like
praise but your Praises if you have a
Shoppers and says oh you look really
great in the outfit yeah it suits you
you must buy it they have an agenda if
your boss says you're amazing at your
job but I need to give you work to do
over the weekend they have an agenda
someone dating you might have an agenda
and your mind knows that when when you
say I'm great at my job I'm smart I'm
kind I'm nice people like me there is no
agenda unfortunately when you go and
rubbish at my job I'm boring I always
mess up and I have no friends
your mind lets that into because your
mind doesn't really care if what you say
is right or wrong good or bad healthy or
unhealthy let me prove that to you I
want you to put your hand in front of
your face like that I want you to close
your eyes I want you to imagine you have
a big fat juicy lemon and I want you to
breathe in that wonderful lemon smell
and just squeeze it a bit and feel that
wonderful lemon texture because nothing
quite smells like a lemon so still
really believing you have half a lemon
in your hand
open your mouth shove that lemon in
there cram that half a lemon into your
mouth and start chewing and sucking and
biting and swallowing the flesh keep
sucking all that lemon flesh into your
mouth bite it chew it suck out the juice
and you will notice what is happening is
your body is responding to a thought as
if it's a fact
your body is responding to the image and
thought of eating a lemon as if you are
actually eating a lemon and it's making
a saliva because thoughts are things
and every thought you have has a
physical reaction in your body and an
emotional response to when you think I
don't have friends I can't talk to
people I can't take things back to a
store I can't ask for special treatment
I don't know how to talk to people then
your mind accepts that as a fact just
like the lemon but when you say
oh I can talk to anyone I'm an
interesting person I'm warm and friendly
people like me and I can make eye
contact I'm good at my job I can ask
someone out on a date I can tell the
person I'm involved with what I need
your mind accepts that too and someone
recently said they keep a lemon on their
desk now and look at it every day I'm
sure they change it every month because
that lemon reminds them every day that
they are responsible for what they think
and feel and you know responsibility
that word means an ability to respond
so I want you to start to praise
yourself I want you to wake up in the
morning the first thing you go is I like
myself we like people who say I've got
something to offer the world
and it's very it's people are very
reassured by confidence you know we're
all scared that we're going to come
across as arrogant but if you're on a
fly and you hit turbulence you want a
convert a pilot if you're sick wouldn't
you like a really confident dog to go oh
I'm the best doctor in New York I'm
Gonna Make You better we don't wanna go
as well
I don't want to brag you know I'm sort
of okay sometimes but you know he's
better than me we don't want our kids
teacher to go well I'm not the best you
know I have good days we want to go I am
the best teacher and I'm going to give
you back your kid in a year's time
radiating confidence and darling you
know we pay for that and yet we're so
scared of saying I've got a gift I've
got a skill this is what I'm good at
people think the brain is really
complicated it's not it's actually quite
simple you only need to know three
things about your brain to always get
what you want and the first thing is
your brain does exactly
what it thinks you want it to do because
it listens to everything you say so when
you say things like oh God you know I
got dumped it's so painful I never want
to go through that again oh your mind
can pick up is you you don't want to be
in a relationship again when people have
a miscarriage and go I could never never
go through that again I'd rather die
than go through that again your mind is
speaking up oh right well that's that's
a statement that's actually a command to
me to make sure you never go through
miscarriage again and that that's how
you get unexplained infertility
which is something else I've been
working on a lot recently because the
mind listens stories we will go oh I
went on this fly I thought it was going
to die and do it again I'm never getting
a player if this plane lands I will
never ever get on a plane again and of
course it lands I go it was just
turbulence but next time they go to the
airport of a massive panic attack
because your mind's like hang on a
minute you said I never want to fly
again
and so if you haven't got what you want
it's because you're giving your mind
very confusing messages your mind's
number one job is to listen to what you
say and interact on it the second job is
to move you towards pleasure and away
from Pain and it will always always do
more to avoid pain so let's imagine
you've gone for an interview you've done
a public speech thing like me and you've
stood up you've got a uh uh and you say
oh my God I'm never doing this again and
you'd have a terrible presentation and
one of my clients who at for Sony was
saying that she had to stand up just say
to Sony this is a new band from Camden
and she stood up and went this is a new
band from
and they're called
uh should I I couldn't do it I just was
the simplest thing and my boss had to
take over and I was explaining to her
that when you do that and go oh my God I
don't want to do it I don't want to do
this again your mind is now going to
make sure you don't do it again so the
next time you go to speak it will give
you a panic attack it'll make you ill
and if you say to yourself oh my God I'd
love a week off in bed or I'm dreading
next Wednesday your mind is so in tune
with you your week off in bed you wake
up with a flu anyone's like there you go
how cool am I there's your week in bed
you don't want to go to that speech I've
woken you up with diarrhea so now you
can't go
that's what the Mind does when I was
giving my first ever presentation about
my first ever book I woke up with the
most excruciating Micron of her hand
would be wrong I thought wow I must have
been saying to myself so I don't want to
do this because I've got this migraine
and I actually went and did it and I
didn't have the migraine until I stepped
back off the stage again and I realized
that I was communicating very badly with
myself so you must never say nervous say
excited because your mind listens so
those three things are your mind does
what it really thinks you want to do if
you're very very specific and say I want
this and this I want to be a great
speaker I want to deliver things I want
to be fantastic at sales I want to be
able to look through online sell them
things and come across as really
authentic your mind will understand and
if you make those pictures really good
when there was a battle between logic
and emotion emotion always always always
wins how many of you have gone to a
really High building and enclosed
building like the top story of a hotel
or the CN Tower in Toronto and looked
down and thought oh wow I feel really
scared my logic my nose that I'm safe
that the glass is that thick that I
can't fall but the emotion that's making
my stomach Lurch is winning so when you
have a battle between emotion and logic
emotion always always always wins here's
something you all know we can all ring
our friend and go I'm a bit bored a bit
lonely can I hang out or I'm a bit bored
let's go to the movie you would never
ring someone you've just met and go I'm
bored and lonely will you come and hang
out with me let's go to the movie
because the emotion that you might be
reject will overall the logic that says
this person may be the person for me so
if you're having a battle between
yourself here's a great one I know I
shouldn't eat cake that's the logic the
emotion is oh the cake feels so good in
this creamy sugary stuff reminds me of
being a baby when all my needs were met
by having creamy sugary stuff so in a
battle doing emotion and logic logic
will never win emotion will always win
and you can make that Win For You by
making it a better emotion so here's how
to do it here's an emotion I'm scared to
ask for a pay rise in case my boss
laughs me out of the office make it a
stronger emotion if I go to my boss and
show them what I've done how valuable I
am that won't happen here's an emotion I
really want to ask that person on a date
I'm not good enough change the emotion
I'm wonderful I'm amazing what could I
get from asking someone on a date that
says yes so much and if they say no I'm
only exactly where I was before except I
had been brave I've done something
courageous I've taken action even if it
doesn't work out I've lost nothing but
I've gained courage so when you're
having a battle doing logic and emotion
emotion always wins logic never wins
that's why you could stand on the
windowsill of your apartment if it was
on the ground floor but you would never
stand on the Windows there same size if
it was a hundred stories out because the
emotion that you may for defeat the
logic that says I can do this when it's
a few feet off the ground why can't I do
it up here because emotion
overalls logic you can make your life
phenomenal extraordinary and wonderful
by always using emotion to defeat
emotion every baby on the world is one
loaded with self-esteem no baby when
they're being pushed down the street in
their stroller goes oh don't look at me
I'm having a hat bad hair day or I've
just been been sick on my little Romper
suit or I got really fat legs babies
first experience on the planet is being
looked at when you're born the doctor
the nurse the Midwife look at you family
come to visit you you get your picture
taken people show you often babies don't
avert their eyes when you take their
picture
when I used to push my little girl down
the street looking her pram go oh my God
she's so gorgeous she never looked away
she kicked her little legs she gave a
big gummy smile because she knew that
she was gorgeous too and if you ever
doubt that children like attention
go to a park go to a swimming pool in
your hair every chugging mummy mummy
look at me on the swing Daddy watch me
on the slide mummy mummy watch me jump
in the wood Watch Me swim watch me jump
because children have this belief that
I'm worthy of attention and I like it
and I can ask for it and I'll get it
then you have to ask well where does
that go well it goes very fast you know
if I say to my little girl look to sing
mummy a song she would sing if I said 14
sing me a song she'd roll her eyes and
go my God you're so embarrassing and
walk out of the room because of a very
early age we require a fear of being
judged it's what is called performance
anxiety what if I sing and someone
laughs at me what if I read in class and
I get it wrong what if I stand up to
speak and I don't know what to say
performance and anxiety can be so
intense that it makes this stop
performing but people who perform really
well like themselves or like I'll see
what happens and I'll sing I'll dance
I'll act I mean some people can't even
dance a party in case everyone is
looking at them
and judging them badly some of my
clients won't even go to yoga in case
they can't hold the poses like everyone
else and believe me we're all so busy
worrying about ourselves we don't have
time to look at you and
comment on your yoga position or how
you're dancing at a party and we kind of
like people who don't care who just let
go and have a good time
so the thing you need to have phenomenal
confidence really are two things stop
judging yourself
and be nice to yourself the very
successful people they do do these
things quite naturally if they have to
fire someone if they have to make a very
uncomfortable phone call they will do it
first and what's interesting is that
they naturally do that they would say
things like well you know I've got to
end a partnership with my best friend or
I've got to fire someone I really care
about I couldn't possibly have that
hanging over my head all day I need to
do it first and then it's done and then
I feel better
people who are not in that group will go
oh god I've got a fire like my friend
I'll do that at six o'clock I'll wait
till the end I'll do that after lunch or
I've got to go and do a grueling workout
I do that at five o'clock but of course
five o'clock comes and you have a phone
call to make or you've just had lunch
and then you don't get to do it even in
school and one of my clients who is very
successful said yeah when we had to you
know read out an essay I never
understood the kids who who went last I
put my hand up and went I'll read the
essay first because I want it done so
they do it naturally but that doesn't
matter because of course the wonderful
thing is that when you do what you hate
first enough times it starts to become
natural like I've got to do my taxes
I'll do that first thing I've got to
confront someone and I'll do it first
and so I still to this day wake up and
think oh I don't really want to do that
so I'm going to do it first because what
I do want is to along to that group a
very very successful people so I know
what the membership is and every time I
don't want to do something I think I
don't want to do it but what I do want
is to belong to that group so I'm doing
it first and it's it's a great way of
thinking because it starts to move you
around wanting to do it for all the
right reasons I always say to all my
clients there's only three things wrong
with everyone everyone has got three
things wrong the number one is I'm not
enough the second one is indifferent so
I can't connect and the third is I
really want something like freedom from
depression or success but it's not
available
but I'm not enough is the biggest I mean
I've worked with hundreds of thousands
of addicts I've never found one ever
that ever believed they're enough
and if we look at the key addiction
shopping
binging on food binging on alcohol
binging on drugs sex sex especially porn
all of those things come from a feeling
of emptiness inside because we're tall
oh you feel a feeling why don't you eat
some donuts or go into eBay and buy or
Amazon buy something or have a drink and
our feelings are the most real thing we
have and we push them down we find all
this stuff to buy or eat or drink or
take to keep us like John Lennon said
Comfortably Numb but then the feelings
regroup and come back because they've
always got a job to do and I would say
to my clients look you've got to feel
the feeling until it no longer requires
to be felt you can't eat it or drink it
or shop it away but we're all tall that
we can and should
so I'm not enough is the biggest problem
but then you have to understand a bit
more of psychology because humans are
hardwired to recreate what they know we
like what's familiar even if that's very
even if it's very bad if I've never had
money and I win the lottery I'm going to
get rid of it or if I've never had love
and you love me I'm going to reject you
because it's so unfamiliar if I've had a
dad who calls me an idiot and worthless
guess what kind of guy I like that's it
because when I meet them I go oh I feel
like I've known this guy my whole life
we just clicked and they think oh my God
it's because he's my dad but I've been
sleeping with them for six months I
don't know what to do with that now
because we are wired to like what is
familiar and to resist what's unfamiliar
and that's what kept us alive when we
lived in water you didn't go a bit bored
with this group I think I'll go outside
the water City and find another tribe
because they might have killed you so we
have this wiring that says run towards
what's familiar and run away from what's
unfamiliar
but the very good news is you can make
anything familiar and the most important
thing to make familiar is praising
yourself that's if you could just do
that that in itself would change how so
your entire life how do you praise
yourself
well you get out in the morning and go
I'm a good person I have a skill I have
a town I have something to offer the
world I'm here for a reason you look in
the mirror and go oh there you are
you're a good person you've got a good
heart you know the most important way to
answer that question is this
what did you always want your dad to
tell you even if you never had a dad if
you had a dad a good dad what would he
have said what would your mama said what
would a nice teacher have said to you
and it would be something like this I'm
proud of you
you're a good son I'm so glad I'm your
dad how lucky I got to have you and a
teacher would say you're such a smart
kid what a joy it is to teach you
because you're smart and we all want to
hear the same stuff I love you I'm proud
of you you're interesting you're great
coming nobody needs to hear on the best
dentist in Beverly Hills because that
doesn't work it's emotions and many of
my clients
their mother might be dead but they're
still trying to get her to approve of
them dads living in another country but
they're still working to make him like
them
and you know the most important thing is
you like you so whatever you wanted to
hear say it to yourself because your
mind doesn't even know that it's coming
and also it doesn't care your mind
doesn't care what you tell it is right
or wrong or true or false or even if
it's good or bad it lets it in like
chapstick on your lips your lips don't
go is this organic fair trade just lets
it in it needs a bit of nourishment and
we need some nourishment and words are
very nourishing and there is actually
nothing on the planet that will raise
yourself esteem like praise
but self praise is better I said to you
just adore you you're amazing by the way
you know can you do this and this and
this I've manipulated you
but if I say it to myself my mind knows
there's no manipulation and the mind
likes repetition and when you say every
day your mind kind of goes oh yeah here
you go again with that praise you say
every day must be true and now it sinks
in in my experience people who try to be
perfect are the unhappiest people in the
world and they're almost always the
loneliest too when you try to be perfect
you have entered a race that you can't
win you can't even complete it there is
no Finishing Line the Finishing Line
keeps moving so when you're in a race to
be thinner happier richer more
successful you can't complete that race
you can't win it and instead of thinking
oh I'm reaching my goals you feel
intense dissatisfaction here's the truth
the way you feel about everything is out
of the pictures you make in your head
and the words you say to yourself and
guess what is so great you can change
the pictures anytime you can change
those words every thought you think
every word you say becomes a blueprint
that your mind body and psyche use
everything at their disposal to make
real thoughts are things what you speak
and think and say without realizing your
mind is working so hard to make that
your reality even if it's super negative
you know I see parents all the time who
say things like I'll be happy when my
kids sleep through the night I'd be
happy with my kids out of diapers I'll
be happy when my kid is walking feeding
themselves going to school and they
spend their whole child's life looking
at the next bit to be happy when you
should be thinking wow I wish every
stage took three times as long you waste
your amazing life wishing it away for
the next bit because happiness is not a
destination you arrive at it's the
journey you're on it's an inside job do
not Farm out I'll be happy when because
there is no terminal to get to good
happiness happiness is the journey wrong
now perfectionists come in all shapes
and sizes and they're often very good at
hiding that inner drive to be perfect
there's one thing that drives them all
and in a belief that says I'm not enough
I'm less than if I'm less than and I can
come across as perfect I'll be more than
you know my neighbors always say to me
wow you have so many famous clients are
they damaged by Fame I'm like no
actually no damaged people are attracted
to fame they have a belief I'm so
damaged but if I'm famous Rich gorgeous
amazing I'll be perfect but you see what
happens when damaged people try to be
perfect
images them more you don't need to be
perfect you don't need to be Flawless
you don't need to be infallible you just
need to be enough and when you let the
fact in that you are enough so they're
trying so hard to be perfect which you
can never achieve when you let in being
enough changes your life so let it in
that you're enough right now because
that's the truth about you what is it
about hypnotism that makes it work is it
that people the things that are open
them up are like buried deep in the
subconscious like why hypnotism why was
that the radical breakthrough hypnosis
is the actual grandfather or even
Psychotherapy people think hypnotherapy
is the poor relative and it's come along
and it's actually in front of everything
a lot of hypnotherapists don't
understand what hypnotherapy really
means and what it means is you can shut
down the critical part of your mind that
goes I could never speak in public oh I
could never live without Donuts that bit
shuts down and while it shuts down you
can excite the imagination and tell
people stuff they simply don't think
they could do so give you an example I
was recently having the medical
procedure and the nurse said oh my God
we all know you and we have this kid and
he can't go in the scanner he's
terrified and I said well I'll show you
what to do and in five minutes he was
loving being in that scanner because I
taught him listen it's how you talk to
yourself if you go I feel like I'm in a
cough in here and I'm Ill and I'm in the
scanner and it's reminding me that I
could die and why would you talk to
yourself like that what you say is I
love this this is amazing I've got half
an hour to chill out and
so people don't understand that what
makes hypnosis powerful is powerful
words but they've got to be super
powerful really Dynamic incredibly
relevant and absolutely up to date and
if you combine that powerful language
with shutting down the critical part
that goes you could never do that who's
going to want you you've got four kids
and cellulite if you shut that bit down
and then add in excitement you can have
anything you want but most people either
don't understand about shutting the bit
down or they don't understand the
language so without diminishing other
therapists I see a lot of people who say
things like now you might just want to
think about being calm it's like what
WTF that's not exciting or they say
things like today you're going to find
it easier not to eat cake and I'm like
come on we can do way better than that
excite the imagination tell people you
love saying no to cake it Thrills you to
pick an apple it alates you to see the
scales going down and your six-pack
emerging because you are motivated and
committed and compelled to say no to
sugar and if you understand the mind it
does what you tell it that's its job and
if you tell it better stuff you have an
amazing life and if you tell it mediocre
stuff you have a mediocre life whenever
anyone does anything wrong we go what's
wrong with you we should say what
happened to you what happened to you and
they'll go well you know my mom always
said she didn't want a girl boy she
wanted a girl and I've been brought up
give an example I had a city Trader as a
client who really had problems trading
and his boss said you know he's the best
Trader but he's so nervous and when I
worked with him he was when he was a kid
his parents had two girls and then him
and he would smash his tongue good to
always going to go what's wrong with you
look at your sisters just combing their
doll's hair and they're so good and why
are you so aggressive and I can't go
well because I have something called
testosterone and they don't and I'm
designed to run and jump and hunt and
fish and I gotta learn what to do with
aggression smashing my cars together is
good for me he didn't four-year-old
doesn't have anything because they live
in the world yeah they just live in a
world of feeling not logic and he said I
never realized just spent my my whole
life thinking something's wrong with me
because my parents would say everything
comes what's wrong with you look how
neat this is they don't get Peas on the
floor when they eat and he said I heard
it every day until I formed a belief
something's wrong with her he didn't
date women because he thought well I
should be like one but I want to be like
a man and that session totally turned
him around he said it was like he's
someone had sprayed it with pheromones
because he went out that night when we
were detaching themselves like a magnet
but he just got rid of the feeling of
something's wrong with me because most
people do walk around getting
something's wrong with me I'm just
majorly messed up
and you can't heal no one understands me
no one gets you yeah and I don't
understand me and if I don't understand
me how can you and why should I even be
here yeah because you can't hear what
you can't understand and so all the
treating the symptom is like putting a
Band-Aid on an infection I don't like
wish wishing says to your mind you
haven't got a prayer but you might as
well wish because wishing just says
you're not going to do that oh I wish no
one says I wish I could get up in the
morning and clean my teeth I wish I
could pick up that pencil and write a
note you don't say we should go I'm
doing it so when you say to the mind I
wish I could it says yeah me too get
over it when you say to the mind I hope
I hope I get this right it goes yeah
we'll keep hoping because you're not
going to do that when you go if only
your mind goes well you never managed it
before so keep on with if only why don't
you because the people have a story now
I can't find a love because my dad left
when I was one I can't find love because
my mum preferred my brother I can't be a
success because I never went to
University
I can't speak in public because I blush
without understanding when you describe
why you can't you keep it going if you
keep talking about the symptom your mind
keeps it alive because whatever you
focus on you get more of and so a lot of
people have language that's completely
irrelevant like yes I know your dad left
when he was one I know your mother puts
you up in the foster care and didn't
love you but that's that's then this is
now and so they have outdated stories
outdated language they I can't do that
because uh the classic when I held him
oh my God my boyfriend just ripped out
my heart stamped all over it killed me
and if I find love again it will kill me
I'm like darling he got bored and you
would have got bored too if you'd stuck
around and that was your starter
relationship go and find a better one
with someone amazing everything he loved
in you you didn't take it home with him
it's still there so don't use that
irrelevant I Found Love and it killed me
when it ended so I found love the wrong
person I'm going to find it again with
the right person it's going to be
amazing and compelling he's going to
fall in love with My Soul gonna be
together forever because you've got to
turn your mind on and it loves exciting
words dramatic words really loves words
that make a pictures of I said
um to you
you can be the most phenomenal powerful
awesome incredible speaker when you
speak on stage everyone stops so listen
you could hear a pin drop they look at
you they hear what you're saying they
like you the Mind goes oh I like this I
know where I'm going but when you go I'm
not bad at speaking sometimes I'm quite
good occasionally I really get it right
the Mind goes what are you talking about
that's not dramatic enough for me and
all psychiators will tell you that the
in if you want to be sorted out here's
something you must do express your hurt
as close to the event that hurt you
happening as possible you can't say to
your dad you know 20 of us for a bike
and you got me a skateboard I didn't
want that what I work nights to buy you
that bike you can't get any resolution
after 10 years or 20 years
but when you can say to your friend look
I love you you're my friend but it
really hurt me when you didn't even turn
up to my wedding and I still had to pay
for all of that and you didn't call and
it hurt me I still love you but you hurt
my feelings then it's gone but when you
keep it in
it doesn't when you say to the friend
you make me feel so angry where you make
me feel angry I didn't come to your
wedding because your guest list that was
extortionate asking for all this stuff I
mean I'm not Bank of America and I
didn't want to buy that stuff but you
can't get resolution but when you say I
was hurt when or I felt hurt by and you
can say it to a wall you can say it to a
force you can say it to a mirror you can
write it down it's not for the other
person it's good to say it because it's
out then and then it goes away it's the
most wonderful thing it goes away and
one of the rules of the mind and it's
the best rule is that every thought you
think and every word you say forms a
blueprint and your mind must work to
make that blueprint real So when you say
I can't remember anything
I'd lose the eyes in the back of my head
if they weren't fixed in there because I
just can't remember anything you mind
because that's a blueprint let me take
you to it and when you say my memory is
phenomenal full but in fact I'm like
human Google when I read an exam the
minute I read the question my mind has
already gone to work found the answer
and I it stays in my head right through
until I write it on the paper then I
read the next question the same thing
happens as I read the question Google
says here's the answer I work with
children all the time with exam stress
and they come in I was a little boy last
year who had um
I think there were 17 children applied
for every place in his school and he
flunked the marks and I'm like darling
you're supposed to flunk them all
because it's great to flunk the mocks
you know what mocks are don't you oh is
there in England when you're taking an
exam you have a mock exam maybe six
weeks before you take the exam just to
see how you do and then they say well
you did terribly you did really well and
because you did really well you're going
to pass that exam and because you did
terribly you're going to fail in fact
the ones who do well in the mocks get so
complacent they often don't do so well
in the actual exam and the ones who do
barely think wow I need to up my game I
need to revise more and study more so
when he came in and said my mummy was so
upset because I got really bad marks in
the market that's fantastic
what were you worse and he said that the
the the this writing and what did you do
is I didn't read the instructions
correctly and I didn't use the right
words but that's fantastic so what did
you need to do and just by changing his
language I didn't use the right words
and explained to him that he could do it
and telling him that his mind was like
Google
then I was asking him some questions
about Harry Potter and I said how do you
know these answers have you studied her
but I went no I just really like it I
said well see how clever your mind is so
when you're working with a kid that says
I don't know awesome about James Bond
ask them about something that they like
and go how do you know this I don't know
how do you know wow you're so smart
because when they like something they
remember and part of school is liking
something so with this little kid he got
into that school I knew he'd get in
because he came in like that and he left
like that he was like I'm gonna nail
this I know what to do my mind is like
Google and I will say to all my clients
whether they're a seven-year-old taking
exam or someone taking a medical exam or
the bar I say whatever you're reading
your focus Narrows down you say the word
narrow down and when you say narrow down
every thing Fades away You're absorbed
in that paper you have phenomenal powers
of concentration
comprehension recall retention and
assimilation and I I say words that help
you the next one comprehension
comprehension retention recall
assimilation I say it over and over
again because the mind believes what you
tell it there's certain rules of your
mind that I like to operate from and one
is the Mind learns by repetition so
nobody would go to the gym I've done 500
sit-ups I should have a six-pack now you
know you've got to go back and do them
again and do them again once you get
that six pack you can keep it with a
little less repetition and so it is with
how we dialogue with ourselves you know
my passion is to get schools to teach
children to dialogue with themselves
better so repetition is very important
but it's not quite enough you know if
you were a chronic alcoholic and right
I'm going to say every day I don't drink
I don't drink I don't drink that
probably won't work first of all the
mind doesn't know what don't is when you
say I don't drink it's like saying I'm
not thinking about chocolate you have to
think about the word that's most
descriptive in the sentence it's like
saying don't think of an orange snowman
now you've got to think of an orange
gnome and even if you've never seen one
in your life
so the combination of repetition
powerful words can be more than enough I
mean somebody wrote to me and said my
kid was lying on the floor hysterical
about her exams and I played one of your
audios she got up to her I'm going to
ace this and she went as well she did
aceit and I could tell even by the set
of her chin that she knew
but for many people they need more they
need you to go back and unpick their
story why do you do what you do what
happened to you why are you an alcoholic
in understanding why for most people
that's their aha moment they go oh my
God I never knew it that's why I do that
oh and then you add in and now you know
you never have to do it again always
have a choice
your mind talks to your body all the
time that's its job and your job
is to tell your mind what you want I
want perfect health
I don't do illness I do Wellness
everything I do is perfect you know I
was at a conference reasoning someone
around them oh my God I'm so glad I
listened to your audio because you know
I have four hours of sleep and I tell my
mind I'm having eight and I thought I
should do that I'm teaching people this
I forgot I can do that too tell my mind
I've had eight hours sleep tell my mind
I feel amazing tell my mind when I'm
working out my body loves this my
muscles are loved this I can do a bit
more rather than go oh it all aches and
I hate doing this and I could be a home
watching TV
so just to be very clear your mind's job
is to do what you tell it and your job
should you choose to accept is to tell
it great things amazing things
I'm not aging I'm saging I'm and I'm
embodying Wellness I have perfect
balance you can choose
not only does the mind tell the body
what to do it also interrupts the
signals coming back from the body I've
got this crippling thumping headache and
become what I've got a little niggle in
my head but I'm really too busy to
notice it I'm in agony no you've just
had a little shot that's not Agony this
commute is hell no hell is not having a
car or any gas and looking at people or
taking three buses to do your commute
being in this store is torture no
when you go to Africa and you see they
don't have any stores and the ones they
do have no food and you'll never again
standing rafts and go this is a
nightmare it's hell grocery shopping if
you have money in your wallet to buy
food to people that love you that is so
far beyond hell but people use these
words that's killing me it's a disaster
it's a nightmare we have a great fear of
rejection which is not surprising
because when we're born we have two
drivers find connection
avoid rejection after all if a mother
rejects a child if a lion rejects the
Cub it's not going to be adopted it will
die yeah or it just starves to death and
so we know innately that our Survival on
the planet is linked to not being
rejected
and not that long ago you would have
died from rejection you know in in a
thousand years ago when they banished
you outside the walls of the city or you
marooned a difficult sailor or you cast
someone out of the community but you
pretty much died there was nothing out
there but Purgatory so we have a wiring
that says rejection will kill me
and that's why you had the fear but when
you can dialogue with no it feels like
it will kill me it can't kill me because
no girl can reject me unless I give her
my permission right give them my power
you can't reject me unless I agree with
everything I don't like you because
you've got short hair I don't like your
shirt I don't like you because you're
white not white at all short glasses not
but when you say you can't reject me I'm
I can't be rejected because the only
person you can reject me is me you can
talk to girls realizing even if they say
no you're not my type I'm with someone
no thanks or even ooh not no they can
only reject you if you let that in and
we look at someone like James Corden
who's certainly not gorgeous but women
love him because he's funny so funny you
know we like warm people you know the
the packaging is all very nice because
we'll have a great packaging a great
wrapper and it'll but they're unhappy
and so our greatest fear is to be
rejected but the truth is in 2018 you
could live in this apartment have Amazon
deliver your groceries never see a soul
and you probably live until you're 106.
yeah wouldn't I advise it but we don't
die of rejection anymore but we still
feel like we will and all schools should
be teaching kids you cannot be rejected
you can ask for a pay rise you can ask
for crowdfunding you can go to someone
go here's my idea you can write a book
speak in public because with a lot of
actors who say I'm so scared of
rejection I'm like well how are you
going to be an actor then
you're you and I write books for
everyone who loves it there's going to
be the odd person because I hate this
book and I hate that writer too but we
don't let it in we have to laugh about
it when you give a YouTube talk I mean
I've got one of my talks about like
three million views and there's a few
and they're going I hate to stuck up
English
um snob but they don't know me because
that's not me at all but I don't go my
God I can never write another book I can
I'm okay because I don't let it in
because the only opinion that matters is
my opinion I know I'm not a stuck up
English snob so that can't hurt me you
are enough is a movement that I started
because you know 33 years of being a
therapist I might work with a movie star
an Olympic Athlete or someone who's a
school teacher and they all have the
same problem and the problem is almost
always I'm not enough I mean I've worked
with so many addicts thousands of
addicts I've never met one who ever
thought they're enough and they'll say
you know
I drink because I'm not enough I use
because I'm not enough I I'm addicted to
spending because I'm not enough and what
I see many therapists doing is the
client comes in with a list like what I
call a shopping list I I need to stop
drinking I need to get out of bed I need
to stop shouting at my kids I need to
take care of myself and they like to go
through the list it takes a long time I
go forget the list let's look at what
what I call What Lies Beneath you know
your problem
I think you're enough where does it do
you know and a baby who's ever been born
because I shouldn't cry because I don't
deserve attention here I shouldn't throw
up on this white top my mom just bleeds
no baby is ever born believing they're
not enough and so again we look at where
does this come from this belief you're
not enough who told you that where did
you get that and when they go oh yes it
came from here
it's a game changer because they start
to tell them I'm enough people say but
if I'm enough don't I just lie on the
couch and eat potato chips all day no
when you know you're enough then you go
right I I need a better relationship and
there's a better career than there's a
better health than this in powerful
language you can never say you can fall
you're going to mess that up you're
going to ruin everything
that's just not going to work out you
have to say the opposite okay I've only
got 10 minutes to prepare my speech I
only need 10 minutes I've only got 10
minutes to get there that's exactly how
much time I need and if I'm late I
wasn't supposed to be there on time I
have a belief now when I get to a party
late it's because it wasn't I wasn't
meant to get there early I no longer oh
my God I'm so late this is going to be
terrible in fact I was recently going in
a cab across town to get a train to work
with a football team and we got stuck in
traffic and so I was playing a game I
thought oh my God I'm going to miss the
train this is terrible I'm going to ruin
my reputation the team are going to be
so upset and I felt really sick and then
I started to say the trains run every 20
minutes it doesn't matter what's 20
minutes my material is so great they
have lots of time after all they're
finished
practicing at three o'clock and and it
was fine so all the way there I was
playing a game
and I actually got the Train on time but
they really wouldn't have minded but I
could have ruined my day made myself
panicky and sweaty but going oh my God I
haven't got enough time and now it's all
ruined and it's never ruined you can
come back from anything and then I
worked with a client who had cancer and
had to go into this MRI scanner and
every time I saw him he's like I can't I
can't do it I can't get in that scanner
and I wanted I said well I feel like I'm
in my coffin I feel like it's a
premonition of my death and I get in
this scanner I think well I've got
cancer and I'm going to die and what is
it will I freak out I press the button I
have to come out and they keep saying
look you've got to go on I can't even be
in there for two seconds which is not
true I can't do it for even a second he
probably was in there for a few minutes
I said look the words you say to
yourself in that scanner this is a
premonition of my death I feel like I'm
in a coffin I feel like I'm suffocating
and I can't do it that's a blueprint and
your mind doesn't like those words so
how about these words how about saying
I'm in my bed at home and I'm just so
chilled and I could lie here for hours
I'm chilled I'm relaxed I'm blissed out
you must use words that make a picture
you can't go oh I'm okay really I'm
quite good I'm not bad this is okay
because when I say the words okay not
bad where's the picture
there's no pictures what I call fluff
when you say I'm chilled I'm blissed out
I'm ecstatic I'm just lying here and I
could do this for hours it's just so
cool the Mind goes you're right and when
you go I'm in a coffin and I'm
suffocating the Mind goes you're right
see here's a great thing you can choose
any words you like you can go well we're
all going to be negative and this house
is going to be positive that's your
choice you know what you can't choose
what you do to yourself when you say I'm
an idiot I'm a I'm a I've
got rocks for brains everything goes
wrong who would ever like me I've got
cellulite I'm a single parent I've got
no chance blah blah blah I didn't go to
college so I couldn't possibly do what
you do I got kicked out of college by
the way so you can definitely do what I
do and it was the best thing that ever
happened to me I can look at my life and
say being fired being dumped and being
kicked out of college thank you God for
putting that in up to me because it
changed my life it was the best thing
rejection has been one of the best
things that ever happened to me being
the least favorite kid if I could have
my life again I'd go back and be the
least favorite kid because I thought I'm
going to show my parents that I'm
something and if I was a favorite I
wouldn't have done that I would have had
a totally different life praise is
unfamiliar but criticism is familiar
when you say to someone like Robin
Williams Oh my God that last show was
funny because didn't you notice
I
fluffed a word it wasn't as good as the
one before so if you're not used to
praise you're reject it and if you used
a criticism you'll add it in because we
do what's familiar so if we say to
someone I love your book they go oh
actually it's not that good the the
other one is much I love your top oh I
got it in a car boot sale it's five
years I've got a hole in it so if we
haven't got praise we actually reject it
and you just have to say to yourself I'm
going to make this familiar I'm going to
praise myself every day it might feel
weird but I'll keep doing it it's a bit
like running you know running isn't
familiar especially around Beverly Hills
but if you put your shoes on and go for
a run on concrete eventually it becomes
familiar and then you like it I mean
sticking a lens in your eye that's the
weirdest thing very unfamiliar the first
few times oh my God I'm coming in my eye
like that and then after a while you can
do it almost without thinking because
you get used to it you can make anything
familiar or unfamiliar your beliefs
affect your world you beliefs certainly
affect your biochemistry I've had women
of 58 say could you make me pregnant I
go I know you it's too late why did you
wait 30 years but the mind will fall
follow your instructions and it's very
important to give yourself the right
instruction of course there are limits
you can't tell yourself you're going to
be an astronaut and women said I want to
be a millionaire like what are you going
to do to be a millionaire you can't go
wrong with sit at home and that's the
problem with the secret attract Millions
to you what are you going to do for
these ones I want to be have a six-pack
you do need to go to the gym I want to
have great health well stop eating pizza
and eat better food but once you get the
mind to want it it's actually easy but
when people say to me I want to be a
millionaire then we tell them well any
goal of significance requires you to
learn something new but then they have a
fear of learning and and of course
you're right then when people come in
and go I want this you have to look at
the blocks the number one block is the
fear of rejection
if I make it I might get rejected if I
find love they might leave if I make all
that money people won't like me anymore
so you've got to smash out of the
ballpark the fear of rejection you've
got to smash out the second belief that
says it's all easy I remember Luther
Vandross saying you know people say I'm
an overnight success I sang Jingles for
KFC for 12 years
it was a long overnight so you do have
to also have that desire
I mean for me you know I speak in public
I write books always aware that
somebody's going to hate your book I
don't like it I'm like oh that's okay
they can't reject me they might reject
my book most people happen to love them
but to get anywhere in life
you have to get over the fear of
rejection
because people think they're going to
die from rejection but they really don't
every day you get to choose how to speak
to yourself you know what you don't get
to choose what you do to your body when
you say I'm an idiot I knew I'd mess
that up I knew that relationship
wouldn't work I've been waiting for it
to go wrong if at the day we got married
I stuck stickers and all my stuff so
when we got divorced there'd be no
confusion
I was already planning the miscarriage I
didn't buy anything for my baby
I mean who does that lots of people
apparently they're all my clients and
they plan for stuff to go wrong they say
I sent my kid to college and I said
don't worry you're probably gonna hate
it here's a credit card so you can get a
return ticket back in a week's time they
plan it
and you don't want to plan it you want
to ban it if someone just comes in and
goes I hate that shirt well that that
color is so not you or you should never
have cut your hair or whoa you've got a
bit heavy you just go thanks for sharing
that just a really simple thing which
says thank you for sharing your opinion
which I can choose to not let in you
don't have to do anything else when the
minute you go your shirt's pretty awful
look at your hair or calling me heavy
you look you you look at a wrecks that
you've let it in and now you're trying
to retaliate and it's like a game of
tennis if you put down your Racket and
walk off the court you can't volley so
the first thing to say is thanks for
sharing that and it's very good the
little barbs we get from people family
friends sisters cousins exes right
um if someone is really mean and says
you know I listen to your talk on
YouTube oh my God you stank up the place
I was embarrassed for you then you go
back and you say I missed that could you
repeat that for me slowly they were
usually not bothered because they know
that in you asking them to repeat it
slowly you're going to call them out on
it and they usually go oh me and my big
mouth I'm just having a bad I didn't
actually really watch it anyway just
ignore me and if they do you must not go
after them and go no I want you to
repeat it right now say it to my face
don't do that because a bit like a lion
who Bears the teeth they're saying back
off and I don't want to attack you when
a lion Bears its teeth you don't go up
to it you walk away it gives you a
chance to retract so saying could you
repeat that slowly is giving the person
a chance to retract the almost always do
but occasionally they'll come out and go
no I just said you're so wooden as a
speaker as an insult to Wood people come
in and they describe you know I really
want to be successful but I'd love to be
healthier but I want to find love but I
can't get pregnant because
and the first thing we do is investigate
like a good detective a detective will
lay out pictures and go what's going on
here and they make sense of it and very
much the same some people come to me
again I've got unexplained infertility
what is that it went well there's a clue
in the in the in the description it is
unexplained nobody knows your husband's
got crack sperm that swims straight and
plenty of it you've got great eggs great
Fallopian tubes perfect womb but you
can't get pregnant because the The
Unexplained is here
and many people when they're younger
will say this if I got pregnant my dad
would kill me oh my God if I got
pregnant with the end of the world and I
remember when I was 17 thinking I was
pregnant oh my God no disaster oh my God
my dad will be so upset devastated when
I wasn't I went on thank you God oh yes
Joy but you see the Mind listens to
everything you say the mind is always
switched on
and it records everything and it never
forgets so
in a moment of absolute Terror or fear
or pain or anxiety there's something
called an imprint it goes in
so a child whose mother says that cat
will scratch you and give you blood
poisoning or that dog's gonna bite you
or that's a dangerous person or you know
I went to a little kid who had a
terrible fear of monsters under the bed
turned out his dad used to say you'll
get run over if you do that you'll kill
yourself if you do that you'll drown if
you do that turned out his dad was the
monster because he was scaring him all
the time so you get a young person come
be an adult you get an imprint and what
we do is investigate where where did
this imprint happen and when we've got
the imprint which is very easy you can
ask questions to get the imprint you can
listen to the client's Story the one who
said my mum used to cry when I brought
up food and so happy when I ate or you
can use hypnosis and go back like that
and the reason I love hypnosis so much
is you go to the imprint you know people
come to see me within five minutes they
have the imprint there's no oh how does
that make you feel and how do you feel
now and let's talk more about that and
come back next Wednesday at four and
we'll keep this going because studies
now say that's that's actually the worst
thing you can do because you just keep
the story alive so we do the
investigation we find the imprint
and then we we interpret it what does
that mean why do you think you know your
dad telling all these stories would now
leave you to have this monster under
your bed why do you think
at 15 being terrified of being pregnant
could possibly mean that today you've
got an Expendable and they work it out
they go yeah now you say that if I look
at those scenes and look at this scene
it all makes sense and then you
interrupt the belief massively and then
you install a brand new belief you know
you're getting pregnant like a high
school kid on their first date you're
super fertile you've got crack grade ax
your husband's got the SAS of sperm and
it's gonna Collide so you bring in the
very powerful language and you are going
to make a grade A B because of course
because I want to be pregnant I'm like
no you don't you want to make a baby
that you carry to full term I have
clothes if I've been pregnant eight
times
you want a perfect bouncing healthy baby
so it's another example of not telling
your mind what you want so the
combination of the imprint the
investigate the interpret the interrupt
and the install
is so powerfully transformational we
tell ourselves the story we play the
only part we've ever known and then that
part becomes our own and we don't know
how to separate it and so people come in
with their story and they go well you
know I nearly I was a newborn baby and
my mum told me that I was only like two
pounds I nearly died that's a drop
milking me with a dropper and I remember
my mum telling me she used to cry every
time I got weighed or if she fed me when
I threw up they would get so upset
because I could die like okay and now
you're 600 pounds because you keep
telling yourself that story
and people tell themselves the story
until it validates why you know my dad
didn't love me he left before I was born
he never came to see me but he had
another kid that you treat like Jesus
bought him everything game boys clothes
so if my dad didn't love me I'm not
lovable and you have to go but that was
then your dad was an idiot that's
nothing to do with whether you can find
love or not
but clients tell themselves this story
and they don't understand that at any
age you can go well I I think it's time
for a new story and so my job is to
first of all find out where where you
know they're coming to go I don't know
why I do this I guess I'm just messed up
I don't know why I can't speak but I've
always been that way I go no no baby
looks away when you look at them in the
hospital no baby goes don't look at me
after having a bad hair day we're all
born with so much confidence you have
four children they never gonna I can't
get a banana in my mouth I I can't get
to grips with this walking reaching
they're they're wired to go for
something but a lot of damage is done
very early and and I see that all the
time really silly things like people
come in and going I I can't ask for
money and then our TT has what I call
interruptions or after they've gone back
they have to then say but that's not me
because and that can't be me because and
that won't be me
ever again and what that does is it
starts to change the neurons it's
actually called
neuroplasticity it starts to change the
way the brain is wired here's my advice
to you expect amazing things then if
what is expected tends to be realized
expect the best it expect love and
success and an amazing life because you
know what it will probably be realized
really fast if you expect it because you
made it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want another amazing Marissa pure video
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there